there's a reason why you're a starving
entrepreneur this did not happen by
accident this doesn't just one day you
wake up and you're starving entrepreneur
you're this concept of people telling me
can't see what you know when you run a
business and you're an entrepreneur
takes several years until you build your
business it's a bunch of nonsense it may
take you a while to build a business but
it doesn't take a long time to learn how
to sell as an entrepreneur make a
six-figure income and your number one
thing to survive as an entrepreneur your
mission is to learn how to sell and make
a six-figure income so that you can
build your business and people said but
so hardpan I work so hard you don't know
how hard I work you don't know how many
hours I'm at the office
look sittin at the office checking
Facebook being away from your family is
not work just because you're at the
office doesn't mean you're working hard
do you how many calls did you make today
how many points did you run today how
many people did you meet with today how
many people did you present your product
today how many prospects did you get
today how many people did you sell today
there's not a day that should go by
where an entrepreneur doesn't sell
somebody look if you go home tonight and
you don't knock out on the couch because
you're so tired of how hard you work
you're not going to make it as an
entrepreneur you're purely leaving it to
luck I hear a lot of people say well you
know a pad I promise your things are
gonna change because you know when I
lose weight watch what's gonna happen
when I lose a watch what's gonna happen
I bet if my family supports me things
will change I bet if that won't Klein
you know that one big client I'm dealing
with if that client by I'm gonna that
clients gonna give me the best referrals
if I land that big sell if my wife would
only support me my husbands I wish my
parents will support me like your
parents support me look none of my
family members supported me they're not
supposed to support you you're supposed
to win their support
they don't one day wake up and say I'm
gonna support you not making money it
doesn't work that way no it doesn't work
that way by the way you should know
everything about the news every single
day if you know exactly what's going on
with Bernie Sanders Donald Trump Ted
Cruz every single thing with the
sporting event every single thing with
every single political candidate if you
know every single thing that's going on
every single place you are acting like
you're already a multimillionaire
entrepreneur running a big business
where those types of things are
important for you to know about you
should know what's going on with every
single sporting event you should
no the latest hit the latest hit - you
should be Kenny G from their 80s you
should not know what's going on every
single day with the news
you should go cell you should go sit
with someone go present someone your
product today if you're going to be an
entrepreneur it is mathematically
impossible to start if you touch 5 10 15
20 people a day and present your product
do you know how difficult it is to make
less than six figures today do you know
how difficult it is to make less than
six figures today today it's so
difficult to make less than six figures
today but it's more than ever right now
here people sending me messages on page
Facebook hey patty can you give me five
thousand dollars it really changed my
life I see how much money you're making
can you show me ten thousand dollars
this won't get a cyber that's had the
audacity to tell me you need to send me
a hundred thousand dollars I told them
why don't you go sell something today
instead of begging for a hundred
thousand dollars he says that's below my
level of dignity below the level of
dignity let me get this straight selling
something in the streets illegally to
make a profit is below your level of
dignity but you're comfortable begging
somebody for a hundred thousand dollars
really really really you're comfortable
with that my gosh but Pat I don't have
the money if I had the money I would
sell something we'll go sell something
you owned and get the money go buy a
product and sell it for a host sell it
for retail no no no I I I'm not I'm not
a salesperson no it's not that you're
not a salesperson nobody's a salesperson
you don't want to go out there and do
the work you want the money to be given
to you for free look if you're going to
call yourself an entrepreneur be an
entrepreneur the first mission as an
entrepreneur is to learn how to make a
living selling your product go sell
something today